i want to bring you a fox news alert the
president has just announced 26
new pardons those include a pardon for
paul manafort
and for roger stone both of them of
course you remember were indicted by the
special counsel
during the russia probe neither stone
nor manafort was convicted of colluding
with russia because they didn't
manafort who was 71 years old was
sentenced to seven and a half years in
prison
partly for tax evasion stone who was 68
was convicted of
lying to congress the fbi colluding with
cnn raided his home
in a pre-dawn raid both were subjected
to
utterly nakedly partisan prosecution
abetted by an activist
judge and d.c based juries stone told
fox news he was watching fox when he
found out about the pardon and has not
received formal notification of this
we wanted to get it directly from roger
stones we're pleased to have him join us
right now by skype roger stone
congratulations
if this is in fact true you're dressed
for the occasion i'm glad to see
is this true have you been pardoned um i
believe it is true
my attorney has now checked with the
white house counsel and we have
assurances that the media reports
are accurate because it was on cnn so
therefore
you know it's a high probability that
anything there is not true but
uh tucker we're very happy i i have an
enormous
debt of gratitude to god almighty for
giving the president the strength and
the courage to
recognize that my prosecution was a
completely politically motivated
witch-hunt
and my trial was a soviet-style show
trial in which the judge
denied us any powerful line of defense
uh in which the judge we now know hid
exculpatory evidence from us because
on new on election day when no one was
watching
the justice department released the last
remaining
redacted sections of the mueller report
in which they admitted that they had no
evidence whatsoever
of my colluding with russia wikileaks
julian assange trafficking and emails
that they had no no factual evidence
that i had advanced notice of the source
or content
of the wikileaks disclosures those
things that i was accused of lying to
congress right now
how does one lie about something that
they have now established one didn't
know
the whole thing has been an outrage
and my hat is off to the president the
greatest president since abraham lincoln
who had the courage to correct this
injustice
so i got to ask you we followed this
pretty closely
simply because it was so obviously
grotesque
even if you had done everything the
accused you of doing the response was so
wildly disproportionate to the alleged
crime you had to ask yourself and i did
every day that we covered this
why what was this about they tried to
put you in prison effectively for the
rest of your life
for lying to congress why did they do
that do you think you've thought about
it a lot
i think it's abundantly clear in july of
2019
the mueller prosecutor specifically
jeannie rhee
approached my attorneys just before the
release of the
mueller report seeking my cooperation
essentially in return
for some unspecified leniency in
sentencing in other words tucker
they wanted me to lie they wanted me to
bear
false witness against the president
and i refuse to do so i think that's
what this charge was about
from the beginning uh they must have
mistaken me for michael cohen but they
had
the wrong guy and i refused to do this
now the left invites invents a totally
new canard which is
stone traded his silence regarding
misconduct by the president in return
for
commutation of his sentence and now a
pardon that is a lie
there is no corroboration or evidence to
prove that
it is the typical rewriting of history
by
the left i always felt watching
what they did to you if they could do
that to you they could do that to
anybody
and so i'm grateful that you have been
pardoned
fully you're now uh citizen in good
standing roger stone congratulations
truly thank you
well tucker thanks for your outstanding
analysis and reporting on this issue you
have been a
paradigm in the truths of the truth so
god bless you
and god bless america and god bless our
president
roger stone thanks so much